après un entretien par visioconférence
le 19 mars dernier
les discussions se poursuivront ce mardi
entre la turquie et l'union européenne
notamment sur la question migratoire
bruxelles met en avant un agenda plus
positif entre les deux parties mais
reste néanmoins mesuré face à la main
tendue par étienne tayyip erdogan depuis
le début de l'année nous allons
collaborer davantage avec la turquie
champ des questions telles que la
migration le financement les dialogues
de haut niveau et la modernisation de
l'union douanière
si la turquie ne fasse pas de manière
proactive si elle revient des actions
unilatérales ou des provocations en
particulier en méditerranée orientale
seront bien entendu ces mesures dès qu
un climat d'apaisement après une année
2001 marquée par une escalade des
tensions entre les deux parties
outre les dissensions sur les dossiers
syrien et libyen ainsi que la
dégradation des relations avec la france
les fortes tensions en méditerranée
orientale ont cristallisé les positions
au deuxième semestre de l'année dernière
en cause plusieurs missions de forage
sur des sites d'exploitation gazière
situés dans des eaux grecs et chypriotes
début mars le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan a réagi face aux
accusations de conquête territoriale en
méditerranée orientale
comme nous l'avons toujours dit nous ne
convoite pas la terre la mer ou la
souveraineté dans notre pays
nous essayons seulement de protéger
notre patrie et nos droits
autre sujet de tension la question
migratoire l'union européenne et
notamment la grèce s'écharpent
régulièrement avec la turquie sur la
gestion de l'arrivée des migrants et
réfugiés vendredi dernier athènes a
accusé les garde-côtes turcs d'avoir
voulu provoquer une escalade en mer egée
en passant très rapidement devant un
navire grec
les gardes-côtes hellénique ont signalé
des multiples ainsi
au cours desquelles les garde-côtes et
la marine turques ont accompagné de
frais le bateau de migrants jusqu'à la
frontière maritime de l'europe dans le
but de provoquer une escalade avec la
grèce il ne fait aucun doute que ces
migrants ont quitté les côtes turques il
puisqu'il était soutenue par la turquie
il ne courait aucun risque nous appelons
la turquie à se retirer de ces eaux a
raccompagné ses migrants en toute
sécurité en turquie et à se montrer à la
hauteur de la déclaration conjointe de
2016 sur les migrations la problématique
migratoire n'est pas récente
la grèce a de nombreuses fois accusé
ankara de laisser les exilés franchir
ses frontières
mais l'accord ue turquie de 2016 a fait
chuter drastiquement le nombre de
migrants en entrant dans l'union
européenne
le renouvellement de cette coopération
sera d'ailleurs au coeur des discussions
à ankara ce mardi